هكذا صرخ المحامي والنائب السابق عن
ائتلاف الكرامه في برلمان تونس سيف الدين
مخلوف اثناء اعتقاله بعد حكم القضاء
العسكري بسجنه هو واربعه من نواب ائتلاف
الكرامه والمحامي المهدي زقربه ومنعه من
مزاوله المحاماه ل 50 سنوات
مع ذلك جبهه الخلاص المعارضه الى اتهام
السلطات بمحاوله اغتيال الحريه وهدم
الديمقراطيه بتوظيف القضاء لحصد خصومها
السياسيين على حد تعبيرها وقالت هيئه
الدفاع ان هذه الاحكام الانتقاميه جابتها
خروقات كثيره واكيده انها تمثل فضيحه
قانونيه وحقوقيه على حد تعبيرها ثم فعل
واحده فعل المطار
فيها حكم مدني والمحكمه العسكريه سمحت
لنفسها بان تنظر من جديد في القضيه خلافا
لكل مبادئ القانون وان تصدر الحكم الجائر
لاصدر
بحكم الدستور وبحكم القانون التونسي لا
يمكن ان تختصر الا في الجرائم العسكريه
ولا ان غابت اي تعليقات او ردود فعل رسمي
عن هذه الاحكام فان بعض انصار رئيسي
يبررونها ويؤكدونا ان القضاء مستقل تفنيدا
للالتهامات التي طالت رئيس الجمهوريه
باستغلال القضاء العسكري لتصفيه معارضيه
كل مكان الاحكام في صالحهم كانت القضاء
مستقل والقضاء ممتاز وعندما يكون الحكم
ضدهم يصبح القضاء غير مستقل يعني سمعت بعض
الاتهامات اصلا للقضاء العسكري ربما مش
معقول همم احنا نعتبره كل الدول تظن انه
الحكم كان قليلا على سيف الدين مخلوف بان
غزوه المطار وذلك الذي قام به اعتبارا
جريمه
القضائيه الجديده تعيد الى الواجهات اذن
بشان ما يراه معارض رئيس قيس سعيد
استخداما للقضاء العسكري في المعارك
السياسيه كما تعيد ايضا اثاره قضيه تصنيف
المواطنين امنيه تحت ما يعرف 17
دي منعهم من السفر
السبب الرئيسي لهذه القضيه يعود الى نحو
سنتين حيث جد خلاف مع رجال امن بالمطار
عندما حاول نواب ائتلاف الكرامه والمحامي
مهدي زقربه الدفاع عن حق مواطنه في السفر
منعتها شرطه الحدود من مغادره البلاد
استنادا الى ما يعرف في تونس باس 17 وهو
تصنيف سري للجدل وصفته منظمه حقوقيه
بالظالم تستخدمه وزاره الداخليه لمنع من
يشتبه فيهم من السفر دون اعلامهم مسبقا
بذلك ودون تقديم اي تفسيرات او ايضاحات في
غياب اي امكانيه للطعن في ذلك القرار حافظ
رباح الجزيره تونس